hello everybody and welcome to part 14
of let's play from dust I'm roughly back
where I was before I killed everybody
with my negligence but I am so tough and
I'm back all right we got two villages
going and I'm just damming this up so
that it doesn't flood this area so I
think I can send people here that's
going yeah that's pouring back into that
ravine that goes nowhere so that's
something and let's see um I don't quite
trust that one until I can get this
which I should get now and this one as
well all right we're making progress I
successfully deflected both this volcano
and that volcano right there so I am in
good shape and I'm not gonna touch this
no I am NOT so let us go away from that
let me put a little more you look like
there's some splashbacks still coming
and that stream is pervasive
it does not want to stop mom ah shut up
since a little water big pansies there
we go ah man I do love that infinite
earth finally finally feels like I have
some control instead of just moving
things back and forth
okay the tsunami is coming soon I'm
hoping that it'll be properly taken care
of but if not wow this has a short
cooldown so I'll just put some more just
in case yep that sounds right Rob right
a little more a little more a little
more a lot more
boom that should be contained
hopefully check it our gigantic dirt
okay and a lesson I learned and if any
of you play this you might want to learn
as well just put some lava around the
edge of where the lava comes out and
then I'll stop vegetation from growing
on it and that'll stop it from catching
fire all the time
oh no don't go now not now oh you're so
stupid
don't die Oh die Oh No
I'm killing everyone I gotta get rid of
this good we could even get really get
me to go to do yeah but I gotta give you
oh no no no no okay good huh okay good
yeah
you don't want that to happen okay yeah
good luck with that guy oh man you guys
are so stupid sometimes I just don't
ah no no no no no no no no no get oh
yeah get Heather yeah so since there's
some there I'm going to just put a dab
of it like aniline here so that it'll
cover up the dirt and make sure no
vegetation ever grows there which is
what we want because oh that's gonna be
a problem
oh no because I got the anti lava one
yeah I do okay we're good we are good
okay looks like I'm finally gonna get
through this ooh that's pretty look at
all that vegetation I hit 100%
vegetation alright I'll go ahead and
send these guys here they hopefully
they're not stupid enough to just walk
headfirst into lava like these guys were
man why did you why you just got split
off oh don't look at me like that girl i
wit okay all right
you guys trap that girls trap
that gonna trap okay wow you're so smart
sho Mart nope nope nope not safe to
build now that too close maybe I could
build a wall around it I don't know I
just do this block the flow of lava it
does not endanger this smart and I'll
top the bridge off it's just a bit of
vegetation so that it is never tempted
to kill everyone around it fickle Beast
Betty I know I'm killing everyone around
it I'm killing everyone around it I'm
killing everyone get get get get get
yeah
get get out of here get out of here okay
yeah we don't want to do that cuz that
would be stupid and murderous oh man
get out of here okay howdy little more a
little more almost done and like that
yeah pretty good ha ha ha ha coming all
right come here no no no no no there we
go okay now what lava to close there is
no lava Oh whatever get just shut up
there is no lava there you've big
pansies
there it took some infinite earth for
you to realize it gosh okay step one of
next level I'm gonna control the
environment before I treat it try to do
anything lava to close you are losers
there is no lava there we go finally Oh
finally
alright buddy for murder
yeah all right that one's doubly
protected that's doubly protected okay
everyone's doubly protected except for
this guy so come on get it populated Oh
what's this hello story go man go woman
sorry I keep mistaking you from a
distance you are very feminine you're
beautiful on the inside and the outside
okay ah c'mon la oh well I can't do it I
know no no no no no amplify my breath ah
get out of there get out there get it
get No where did that come from and it's
just non-stop I don't even understand
get out of the way guy you're gonna get
burned alive if you stay there boo boo
boo boo okay
alright fine Oh who needs help now who
needs help now who's in trouble
no one false alarm
fire under control maybe no it's not no
it's not not under control is not there
we go okay now it is now it is okay
alright yeah yeah
Oh whoo damn man I get a little engulfed
all action okay this guy what do you
need help with what what you're right
there okay yeah smart one
all right ah no oh you got to be kidding
me
well that's stupid why would they put it
right there
all right fine but I'm gonna find a
better way to channel it how would I
oh no I can just jellify the water right
okay send people there they'll get to
the rim on jellify the water amplify my
breath no amplify and engulf all and
jellify water yeah that's perfect
oh yeah I'll get ready for this all
right
oh I'm getting smart guys I'm getting
good at this game
all right you're at the edge now I
jellify engulf amplify my breath there
we go pressing the wrong mouse button
okay oh yeah look at that
get out of here good now if you can make
it I think you're good you can make it
make it get down there oh no get away
and go fall I need to put some dirt I
need to put some dirt BIRT some dirt
which I'm dirt okay here we go here we
go oh I could have just I guess raised
it out of it
ground that would work too okay go go
there's not much time peeps bone up
being so slow
oh man what you can't make that totally
on a 90 degree incline geez you pansies
all right hang on I'll get more earth
boo tutors dude you all right infinite
earth I'll wait for the amplify breath
because oh no water hey maybe these
problems gonna solve itself or maybe
they're all gonna drown yeah it seems
more likely they're all again drought
nope no no yes come on right there how
about now how about now feeling safe
feeling secure how about now but now a
my benevolent enough for you come on
you're right there bacha wusses get out
of here you're right there get it okay I
don't think I can make it any more
available to you so I don't even know
how you got there I mean man that is
just I was just negligent behavior you
you brought that on yourself okay
moving forward find a lead
yep into the mouth again the weird weird
mouth alright I hope the next map is a
bit more of a challenge for me cuz I'm
obviously getting way too pro in this
game
Oh what's my challenge no land at all I
like it
how did it not drown the cave they're
coming in that should have been flooded
but whatever ooh that's cool dunya nice
edenia kita CT Lapidus a llama
yeah probably edible delicious allah ah
where da de Topeka Valentia dalla ah
okay we're not alone here in the middle
of a vast emptiness
everything must begin with the breath
and with the giant who awakens help the
tribe to settle in and using everything
the sea has to offer
okay but that is gonna have to wait
until next time guys thank you so much
for watching and I will see you in part
15 of let's play from dust
bye bye